(Hudson)
[as Dazzle]
Sorry it had to be this way.
Also, you should know
I'm your father.
Daddy,
forgive me stealing bike.
Keep going!
It's just locusts!
Should we chase after the set?
No.
The desert is now our set.
[intense electronic music]
♪ ♪
(Dazzle)
All right, Hudson!
When we cut the wheel loose,
you run like hell...
because it will crush you!
Why is it so big?
It's forced perspective.
It's gonna look normal size
on camera.
Now, crew,
this goes without saying,
but please do not fight
the rebels during the take.
I know you're in a violent
struggle for your homeland,
but I need your hustle, okay?
Lights, camera, actualize
the events from the script!
[screams]
[groans]
Oh, no!
Money!
I mean, Zephyr,
I didn't mean to crush you.
No feelings of hardness,
my friend.
Your reenactment is only work
of value I ever produce.
Promise me two things.
[coughs]
You will finish
this reenactment,
and you will bring Zephyr
back to life!
Unless they discover a cure
for crushed body,
I can only promise the first.
This true.
There's blood in the streets.
Don't forget to buy.
[groans]
All right, let's clear this
corpse and go right away.
Big smiles.
Why aren't we shooting?
[gunfire]
Zephyr is dead!
The cruelest among us will now
fill the power vacuum!
Stop shooting each other!
Save your ammo for the rebels!
[helicopter blades whirring]
[gunfire]
Hudson!
Jump on the Novak-cam!
Ho!
To freedom!